[Music]
this of course is segment where viewers
try to find mistakes on our show we're
the only show that says hey try try to
find a mistake on our program so far
hundreds and hundreds of challengers not
one winner not one person has won yeah I
don't know whether it's funny yeah I
didn't you there are no mistakes on this
show it's a perfect gem well today a fan
named IU 872 zero says he thinks he
found a mistake he said I made it when I
talked about a news story about a woman
who was arrested at the airport for
carrying $40,000 in her bra hello I just
watch those show about the correction I
think I found a mistake
you just mentioned a lady had $40,000 in
her bra but actually I read that news
it's in bra and her suitcase it's too
much to put in a bra
so I sent me bass to you thank you like
I said we've done this hundreds of times
everyone else is accusing me of making a
mistake and often they can be you know
kind of harsh or obnoxious about it can
be dicks about it thank you Andy this is
my interpreter yeah I you was so polite
he's wonderful
and he's yeah it's like he's he's asking
me is it possible you made a mistake and
I appreciate that I you which is why
it's so painful for me to tell you
you're dead wrong you are so wrong I you
$40,000 can easily fit in a broth and I
decided to prove this fact myself when I
took a rather enjoyable excursion
recently take a look Hey which of you
ladies wants to find out if $40,000 can
fit in a bra okay you baby in the blue
you didn't see that coming
the old switcheroo
[Applause]
you always look it's the guy who's too
hot in the audio oh there he is it's the
show that uses actors multiple times
crowds turning on us Andy they're angry
about that no it's a good thing they
can't hear me because I'm shielding we
don't have to pay him once exactly the
challenge still stands ladies and
gentlemen if you think you've sported an
error on our show reported at team
koco.com slash haha i found an error we
will swear it out right here on the air
let's see if you've got what it takes to
make chunk meat out of the my strip
we'll take a break when we come back
where's the Tom a is here
you